The SCP Foundation is no stranger to pure
evil.
Whether it’s a reptile that wants to end
all life, a sadistic old man with his own
torture dimension, or the personification
of death itself lurking beyond a limestone
cavern.
But what if there was something even worse
out there?
The embodiment of chaos and cruelty, existing
across multiple realities and dimensions.
And what if it was coming for us.
This is The Scarlet King - believed by many
to be the ultimate evil behind much of the
trouble the Foundation has faced and some
even speculate that fighting him was the reason
the Foundation was created in the first place.
But what exactly is the Scarlet King?
He’s known by many names, almost always
including some allusion to the color “red”,
and then a reference to royalty or power-
Harak, Khahrahk, the Red Shah, the Crimson
Khan, PTE-616-Mendes-Ex-Machina, the Lāla
Rājā, and of course SCP - 001 to name a
few.
And like many of the Foundation’s mysterious
enemies, stories about his true nature and
origins abound and are often contradictory.
According to the official SCP - 001 files
of Tufto’s proposal, symbology of the Scarlet
King has existed in multiple cultures throughout
history, with the king often depicted the
same way, as a huge, red demonic figure, often
wearing a gold crown of other headdress indicating
royalty.
He shows up looking similarly within different
cultures’ mythologies, despite existing
at different points in history or them not
having the means to communicate with one another.
A number of entities that the SCP Foundation
is familiar with are believed to be somehow
connected to the Scarlet King, including SCP
- 2317 - a wooden door leading to the realm
of a being known as the Devourer, who’s
expected to escape and cause an apocalyptic
event in the next thirty years.
But really, there’s no way of knowing just
how many SCPs are directly connected to the
Scarlet King.
Strangely, the Foundation's official file
on the Scarlet King once designated his containment
class as Keter, but that has since been downgraded
to Safe.
According to the file, any attempt to change
this designation is likely to lead to horrifying
results.
It is widely known that the Scarlet King still
has considerable influence over a number of
groups, individuals, and anomalies in our
universe, and if ever he made his way into
our universe, it would likely lead to the
irreversible damage of reality itself, so
then why safe?
And why are the O5 Council so adamant that
it remain that way?
Getting to the bottom of this mystery is exactly
why we’re here today.
But, to fully grasp the true nature of the
Scarlet King, we must first understand the
man whose life and fate have always been tied
to it: Dr. Robert Montauk.
If that name feels oddly familiar to you,
it’s because of its association with one
of the Scarlet King’s most recent attempts
to enter our reality: SCP - 231.
This SCP, often referred to as the Brides
of the Scarlet King, was formed of seven women
- seven, by the way, being an extremely significant
number for the King - all kidnapped by the
most recent in a long line of the King’s
devoted cults known as The Children of the
Scarlet King.
Each of these seven unfortunate women were
impregnated with anomalous horrors, such as
the infamous SCP-682, and every time one of
these horrors were birthed, a catastrophe
occurred and the mother died.
At the time, Dr. Montauk was a prominent researcher
studying this anomaly, and as six catastrophes
had already occurred, pressure was mounting
to figure out a way to prevent the final birth.
But as he was working on the issue, Dr. Montauk
was struck with a personal tragedy - The mysterious
disappearance of his 14 year old brother,
Jacob.
In his fear and anger, Montauk believed that
this must have had something to do with the
Scarlet King and his disciples.
Wanting revenge, Montauk proposed an idea
so horrifying that the details were never
made public - a procedure known as 110-Montauk
to be performed on the final bride at regular
intervals.
However, this wasn’t the end of Dr. Montauk’s
fraught relationship with the Scarlet King
- it was just the beginning.
To give you some perspective on just how dangerous
the Scarlet King is, the SCP Foundation and
the Global Occult Coalition decided to put
aside their differences and form a joint effort
to stamp out the Children of the Scarlet King.
They were successful in this mission, and
even managed to capture the Children’s leader
- a mysterious man named Dipesh Spivak.
Dr. Montauk, who’d become the lead researcher
on 231 and 2317, was naturally the first choice
for interviewing Dipesh about the true nature
of The Children and of The Scarlet King.
Dr. Montauk could never be the impartial interviewer
that the SCP Foundation wanted though, the
suspicion that the Scarlet King or the Children
had something to do with the loss of his younger
brother, still lingered just beneath the surface.
Like a lot of cult leaders, Dipesh was extremely
cryptic in his answers to Dr. Montauk’s
questioning.
He’d already heard of the doctor from the
reputation of the horrifying Montauk procedure,
and was surprised to see him so calm and courteous
in person.
A few key facts about the King and his cult
were revealed in the first few rounds of questioning:
The Children had once worked with the Serpent’s
Hand before being excommunicated for their
allegiance to the King, and they had stolen
sacred texts from the mystical Wanderer’s
Library to assist in their summoning rituals.
Dipesh also revealed that the Scarlet King
is bound by three Laws - the Law of Blood,
the Law of Concrete, and the Law of Howling.
Dr. Montauk, confused and frustrated by Dipesh’s
secrecy, had to learn more.
He found an old memoir from a former member
of the Children of the Scarlet King, Jack
Hearst, who had the ability to invade the
minds of people from the past and experience
what they experienced.
He recounted a battle between the Scarlet
King and his followers and a group of time-traveling
Turkmen warriors from SCP - 3838.
Hearst saw both sides of the battle.
From the perspective of the Children of the
Scarlet King, their lord ruled over them from
an immense fortress embedded in a volcano.
From the perspective of the Turkmen, the Children
were starved and beaten peasants, commanded
by the King’s voice in the roaring howl
of the wind.
Montauk also found extensive records of summoning
rituals performed by various Scarlet King-aligned
cults.
Interestingly, some of them incorporated the
use of carved SCP Foundation symbols.
What could this mean?
Montauk returned again to Dipesh, who finally
gave him the truth about the Law of Blood.
This is the Law of the Scarlet King - it’s
defined by poverty, violence, starvation,
hate, and most of all, fear.
Like the serfs in the Middle Ages, persecuted
by and subjected to violence from the nobles.
To the Children of the Scarlet King, this
sense of holy pain and awe is the only way
to live.
The alternative is the Law of Concrete - which
means the modern age, defined by empty safety
and false comfort.
Buildings, easy to access food, healthcare,
knowledge, technology.
This is everything that the Scarlet King despises.
But the mystery only deepened as Montauk found
files from a former Foundation operative by
the name of Agent de Beauvoir.
Montauk learned that the Scarlet King didn’t
seem to appear until after the Foundation
was created, and in fact, it seemed that the
greater interest the Foundation took in the
Scarlet King, the more powerful he became.
How could this be?
Things were also getting stranger on a personal
level for Dr. Montauk - Dipesh repeatedly
pressed him about his brother’s disappearance,
and the Montauk Procedure, during the interviews.
Little by little, it was beginning to take
its toll.
The questions still plagued him: What was
the Law of Howling?
Who or what really is the Scarlet King?
How did he come to be?
Montauk’s search was causing him to act
more like the Children of the Scarlet King
- ranting about the horrors of the modern
world, how all of us are living a lie.
how the only “honest” way to live is suffering
under the dominion of the Scarlet King.
This philosophy is summed up in the words
of one cultist named Ariadne Cartwright who
said:
“We must learn what it is to die.
To be enslaved- truly, brutally enslaved,
with no compassion or compunction from our
masters.
We must learn what it is to be taken towards
a single purpose, to know and truly understand
our lack of agency.
We must be beholden to a world of gods and
darkness, the tempest-tossed refuse of a race
of fools.
We must kill modernity, postmodernity, with
all its analysis and sneering observation.
There is only one rule; the rule of chaos.
For humanity!
For life!
For the Scarlet King!”
Basically, any time humanity tries to exert
control over the world, the Scarlet King gets
stronger.
Every time they try to understand or organize
or categorize their world, the Scarlet King
gets stronger.
As colonial and imperial powers conquered
and invaded lands like India, Africa, and
South America, and subjugated their beliefs
under western ideas, the Scarlet King got
stronger.
Montauk was beginning to truly understand
the power of his enemy here, and even worse,
he was starting to understand his part in
it.
Montauk, slowly being driven mad by the knowledge
he was gaining, realized that the Scarlet
King’s greatest enemy - The SCP Foundation
- was also its greatest asset.
Every time they tried to understand the monster,
to give him some kind of comprehensible form,
they only made him more powerful.
Just in time with Montauk’s new revelation,
a red crack appeared in the wall of Dipesh
Spivak’s containment cell - a portal to
the realm of the Scarlet King.
Foundation staff found that they were unable
to enter the cell, and Dipesh demanded a final
interview with Montauk.
With no other options, the Foundation relented.
In their very last conversation, Dipesh congratulated
Montauk for finally understanding what he
was dealing with.
The Scarlet King, Dipesh told him, is an idea,
a concept.
He is a being given power through the conflict
between the old and new.
This is the Law of the Howling - The Scarlet
King’s endless rage at the direction the
world and humanity has taken.
The King, according to Dipesh, hated the Foundation’s
belief that science and rationality was the
true path to progress.
The King saw this as little more than petty
arrogance.
The reason Montauk’s Procedure on the final
Bride of the Scarlet King was so effective
was because it wasn’t born out of science
- it was born out of hate, pain, the desire
for revenge, and in the Scarlet King’s realm,
that would be all there is.
Unless our world, and especially the Foundation
changed course, the Scarlet King’s rise
to absolute power would be inevitable.
Montauk, his mind practically gone, asked
one last question: Did the Children or the
Scarlet King take his brother, Jacob?
When Dipesh told him the answer… no.
And in response, Montauk shot him dead.
Finally bringing an end to the Children of
the Scarlet King.
In light of his new revelations, Montauk begged
the O5 Council to change their ways in order
to avoid letting the Scarlet King break into
our reality.
They refused, saying Montauk’s ideas were
too radical.
But they knew they couldn’t just ignore
the threat posed by the Scarlet King, they
would have to take some steps.
And so, the O5 council of the SCP Foundation,
the most powerful and secretive group in the
entire world, in order to prevent the most
dangerous threat that humanity has ever known
from breaking into our reality and enslaving
all the people of the world, finally did something.
They changed the classification of the Scarlet
King from Keter… to Safe, and made its description
on the official Foundation files deliberately
vague.
The O5 council thinks this will be enough
to stop the Scarlet King’s power from continuing
to grow, but Montauk knew it wasn’t enough.
He had seen the truth, and he couldn’t unsee
it.
While the Foundation was going on as normal,
Montauk grew to despise them.
He knew the Scarlet King was coming, he knew
that he couldn’t be stopped, and that our
whole reality was little more than sitting
ducks.
Dr. Robert Montauk is no longer a researcher
for the SCP Foundation, no Dr. Robert Montauk
chose a different path.
He’s now a child of the Scarlet King, a
devotee of madness, hate, and chaos.
You can’t beat the Scarlet King after all,
and as the old adage goes, “If you can’t
beat ‘em, join ‘em.”
Now go watch “SCP - 682 - Ways The Foundation
Tried To Kill The Hard To Destroy Reptile”
and “SCP - 4999 - Someone To Watch Over
Us” for more about the strangest and most
mysterious entries in the SCP Foundation’s
database.